in between my sophomore and my junior
year in college i had what i call the
summer of four jobs and
three of them were pretty crappy and one
was not too bad
and the summer began with the three
crappy jobs and then finished up with
the job that i actually found to be
kind of decent
and the reason why i had so many jobs
was in part because three weeks tends to
be about how long i'm willing to put up
with a job that i really can't stand or
at least was back then
and
i began the summer by moving in with my
fiance into
a portion of a house that was being
rented out by us
in sheboygan falls now she was a local
girl from sheboygan
and her dad was a worker at the kohler
factory until he injured his back very
early on i think he was 19 or 20 years
old so he was on permanent disability
and her mom worked for ups i don't
remember exactly what she did she wasn't
loading the trucks or anything like that
but she was doing something for them
and
you know i was from down here the
greater milwaukee area and specifically
by at that time waukesha where my mom
had relocated
and i was living up there you know to be
able to spend time
you know together with my fiance over
the summer kind of laying down roots you
could say the previous summer i had come
back down here
and i worked the entire summer for
shakey's pizza i've talked about that in
another
video that was the summer that i also
worked at summerfest for shakies and um
you know we visited back and forth and
you know we're young and and
at least thinking that we're in love
and so you know that summer we didn't
get to spend as much time together so i
wanted to you know stay up there
and her family was very
very very uptight about the need to have
a job now you know we actually had
enough for our rent and i had like the
next uh year of school basically
covered for room and board and all of
that sort of stuff um you know i was
taking out a student loan but you know
it was very very important in their eyes
that i'd be bringing in money and i
think that i had a job it was sort of
like a
what would you call it like a class
thing or a prestige thing
and i'd never actually seen this sort of
thing i mean i rarely have been without
a job
in the course of my life but i'm cool
having a couple weeks where i'm not
working from time to time you know i
don't i don't have money necessarily
coming in um or you know i don't have a
place to be
but for them that was like a sign that
you were a degenerate and so
as soon as the summer started as soon as
the school year was over there was a lot
of pressure you need to get a job
and
in that area at that time factory work
was considered like particularly good so
everybody wanted to get into bemis for
example you know where they paid pretty
high wages or failing that you know into
kohler or one of the other factories and
so i ended up applying for a
job in a factory called jl french and
they made
cam covers and oil pans and i want to
say some other car parts as well
out of die cast aluminum
and i got the job predictably enough it
wasn't hard to get a job like that you
basically have to be able to you know
show that you've worked before and can
fog a mirror because the class of people
that were working there uh before they
washed out was was pretty low
and so you know i start working there
and you come in and you've got your
steel toe work boots and you know you're
dressed in your jeans and other like a
t-shirt and stuff like that and the very
first thing you got to do is pick out
your work gloves because working with
this die cast aluminum if you don't wear
gloves it will just tear your hands to
shreds quickly and you want to make sure
that the big barrels of gloves you want
to make sure that you've got like gloves
that are really
solid not ones that are all torn up all
already
i learned that mistake the hard way you
know getting some chafing and blisters
and stuff like that
and so the first day they put me to work
on a machine called the blaster and it's
got all these little tiny pellets of
steel that it you know you put all the
parts that you get out of a giant crate
onto these
lattice works you could call them sort
of like armatures or skeletons and then
they go through the machine and the
machine bombards them
with these uh little tiny steel pellets
which go everywhere right um
going under the machine going outside
you're constantly sweeping up these
things and they're getting your hair and
you know all over your body as well as
you're sweating but they would put a
nice finish on to the cam covers and oil
pans
and then you pull them off and you put
them back into crates and now they go to
another part of the factory and you know
it was pretty hard work it was very hot
in there it was always like but in our
part of the the factory it was about 100
degrees fahrenheit
they were doing the die casting and you
know molding and stuff like that in
another part of the factory where it got
up to like you know 130.
so it was uh you know it was tough work
didn't pay particularly well
and i probably would have stayed there a
while but
they um started me doing two other
things
that i didn't really care for
um one was doing this testing to like
seal
testing in in an area that you put the
thing under water and it would like
shoot air through it and then like if
you saw air bubbles you could tell the
part was defective and you'd have to put
it aside i think it would just get
melted down and reused
and i hated that in part because your
fingers would get all like wrinkly but
the worst part was your work boots and
your socks would get soaked
and
that was very uncomfortable and it paid
basically the same and then after a
while i'm not sure why they they sort of
figured that i was a good guy for this
but they started trying to apprentice me
to the tape and band man and this is the
guy who had kind of a privileged
position
within the the factory because you know
not too many people could do what what
he did actually i think any anybody
could have done what he did with proper
training but it was to like package all
of these parts in certain ways and make
sure things went to the right spot now
there were only a few of these guys and
this guy was a nut job as a matter of
fact i i recognized him later on when i
worked a different job later on
in sheboygan falls
behind the counter of a convenience
store as being essentially what we would
nowadays call a tweaker he was addicted
to these over-the-counter
supplements or whatever they were called
that you could buy at the time is
basically legalize speed and so the guy
was not a very good communicator and
he's getting mad at me for not getting
everything right away
and around the same time
my wife's
not wife my fiance's dad
had uh said well i know a guy who um is
looking for somebody to help him out and
he'd pay you cash money
uh and it would be you know a better job
it's tree cutting service and i was like
well okay i'll go and and you know meet
with the guy and and you know he and i
chatted and i could tell there was stuff
that was off about him and i'll tell you
about that in just a moment but he was
offering better money than jl french and
he's like
show up uh you know a couple days from
now and we'll go through
the whole thing and so i quit my job at
jail french after you know about three
three and a half weeks
and started working for this guy and
he had a you know like i said a tree
cutting service if you don't know what
that means you know he's he's got a big
dump truck a two and a half ton
that would um you know haul this big
wood chipper behind
and he had you know chainsaws and other
kinds of mechanical saws that you use to
cut up you know tree branches that need
to be trimmed or sometimes take a whole
tree down right and then you got to cut
the thing up and i'd worked with
chainsaws before in the army i i enjoy
that kind of work it meant being outside
not stuck in a
super hot factory uh you know doing
second shift
and
so i was like oh this is gonna be cool
right
well you know that part of the job
actually was he was a complete
a-hole um he was what we would nowadays
call a
rabid
maga american
he would you know he began the morning
with coffee and watching fox news and
throughout the day he'd be complaining
about the immigrants the jews the blacks
the gays the this the that and just a
complete sourpuss you know and i'd more
or less just ignore his [ __ ] and
racism and he was also like a really
crude sexist as well obviously not
married obviously not dating anyone
because he uh rarely bathed and looked
like crap and ate like crap and
basically had a crap you know mentality
and so i you know i worked with him and
i there was another guy that i worked
with who was a vietnam vet who only had
one lung but was still smoking anyway
that's the kind of stuff that you know
very often is the case when you work for
stuff like that and you know
it paid pretty well
but you know it was getting more and
more irritating to deal with this guy
because he was just such a raging bigot
he couldn't like shut the hell up and
just like get on with the work and i
would you know i was getting frustrated
as well sometimes with the machinery
and
one day you know the wood chipper wasn't
working right it got clogged with
something i couldn't figure out how to
get it unclogged and i was working on a
site by myself
where he'd done the cutting and i was
just supposed to take care of it and i
was like
man screw this and i drove the truck all
the way back to his place you know left
the keys in it wrote a note said i'm
done i'm i'm not working for with you
anymore
and uh got in my car and took off i will
mention there was one other good thing
about that job which is i you know i had
i had a friend who tried to teach me how
to drive stick before
and i wasn't really able to master it in
in high school and
in this job i had to learn stick
because um the two and a half ton dump
truck that we were using
was it was a stick right and so i had to
learn how to
do stick in the first place and then do
engine braking and stuff like that so
that was that was kind of cool you know
getting to to learn that that was quite
helpful
and it was a lot of fun driving this big
truck around
you know and cutting stuff up and you
know but
he was just such a raging jerk i didn't
i didn't want to hang out with him and
you know i quit that and then of course
my fiance's dad is ticked off at me my
fiance's ticked off at me because now i
don't have a job so i start going to the
want ads you know for those who who
don't you know remember this or
who aren't old enough
for this to have been the experience in
the papers you would have all these
advertisements for work like we're
looking for workers to do this and this
call this number show up at this place
or apply here
so
one of the jobs that i applied for was
at walmart in sheboygan
and i'd been there before shopping
never really paid much attention to it
although my my fiance and her family
were you know like big walmart shoppers
right so they actually they're very
happy that i was working at walmart
and uh i show up and they do some
orientation stuff i'd actually worked in
a walgreens before
so i'd done stocking and you know
customer service you know doing a cash
register all that but they trained me on
it anyway and this this tells you how
long ago this was
back then the policy at that walmart and
it may have been at many other walmarts
was that
men could not be cashiers you know
working in front at the cash registers
unless there there was like you know too
many uh customers and then they would
draw you know male
workers to the front to be cashiers
temporarily but it was supposed to be
women and things are very very sex
segregated so obviously you're not going
to work in women's clothes or jewelry
you could work as a guy in lawn and
garden
um electronics
men's clothes obviously
and
then where i ended up working which was
sporting goods and automotive now
sporting goods
includes like everything having to do
with sports you know everything that's
got
a ball or you know a basket or anything
along those lines and it also included
um fishing
and boating stuff which was kind of cool
because you know i was a big fisher
person and i i knew about boats but then
there was the automotive and they had
all these different products for
automotive stuff most of which don't
actually work and you know they're for
gearheads they're for people who like
working on cars i've always approached
cars as basically a means to the end of
getting me to where i want to go i don't
care about cars
i'm not into them or anything like that
and but i was expected to you know
help people out with them and so they
would come to me and they'd be like you
know here's an stp product is this going
to improve my mileage and at first i'd
say stuff like
i don't know i mean let's take a look at
the package and see if it says anything
useful and then they'd get mad at me so
i was like
screw this i'll just tell them whatever
they want to hear yeah of course that's
gonna you know improve your mileage i
use it my car all the time and i just
[ __ ] people about that sort of stuff
to keep them off my back because it's a
minimum wage job and you know if you're
stupid enough to ask somebody some some
kid in in you know automotive who
probably doesn't know anything about it
uh some questions well you're gonna get
crap answers so i did that the sporting
goods was kind of fun the weird thing
about sporting goods though was that
guns because of hunting were included in
sporting goods so we would sell fishing
and hunting licenses there we also sold
a lot of guns especially shotguns
and rifles sometimes pistols though too
and knives of course people are always
buying knives and one thing that i
remember about selling all these guns
was you could not sell guns
and ammo
to the same customer
in the same purchase they had to be
purchased separately and you wouldn't
allow them to have the gun and the ammo
at the same time if somebody was buying
both of them then somebody else in
sporting goods in automotive had to
either take the gun or take the ammo and
walk it to the door along with the
person
and then you know once you got to the
door and they went out of the door you'd
give them the ammo so obviously if they
wanted to shoot the place up they they
could have done it quite easily but you
know at least you were like covering
your bets i suppose
and uh and that's that's what i did for
you know
about another three three and a half
weeks or so
and i was starting to get the hang of it
you know it wasn't too bad i was getting
to know my co-workers and you know
settling into a kind of routine and then
i got a call
from
lakeland college
and it was quite interesting they said
hey um
we are getting rid of our
our security guards that we've got and
we're going to start a whole new
security guard thing we've got somebody
to run it we just need a bunch of
officers your ex military would you be
interested in doing this sort of thing
and i was like
uh yeah that sounds pretty good and so
you know we had to do some training
which was fine and they gave us uniforms
and then we had um you know our shifts
and i started working second shift which
was kind of nice because it's it's you
know cool and dark and you know you just
walk around and i'd be on till like five
in the morning or so
and then um
they made me second shift supervisor so
now i'm like you know the the second in
command from this other guy and you had
keys that would get you everywhere on
campus you could do stuff like if you
wanted to make yourself a little meal
you'd go into the cafeteria and open the
place up and get yourself some cereal or
make yourself a sandwich and it was kind
of cool to walk around the campus and
just to see all of the different things
from different perspectives like for
example at the uh the mathematics and
science building where i i did a lot of
my classes there were all these lights
outside and so because of that there are
all these massive spider webs because
the spiders would have you know insects
flying into them and they'd get giant
just huge you know like their bellies
like that fat and you you watch these
spiders and you know walk out by the
little lake that they had and
go through the different steam tunnels
underground and you know it was it was
pretty cool there was also a lot of
boring
time involved in that and uh you know
sometimes there'd be things happening on
campus and you'd have to write people up
or intervene or stuff like that but it
was a it was a pretty decent job overall
and it didn't suck like these other
three factory tree cutting and walmart
job did so that's how i basically ended
that summer and you know kept my fiance
and her family off my back because i was
gainfully employed
i think they probably actually thought
it was like better than the other jobs
or something like that
and uh that's you know that that was
that summer i did a lot of working i've
you know more or less worked every
summer i think
uh except for the one um where i went to
you know come back into to europe in
between uh undergraduate and grad school
um when i was working here in milwaukee
for a year but that's a whole different
story so that is the summer of four jobs
maybe you find it interesting
but it certainly was a
lot of work on my part
over that time and i you know it was not
the happiest of times but i do enjoy
working and i can usually find something
at any given job that's
you know interesting or enjoyable so
that's the whole story
you